pendant la campagne nos équipes vont se
promener dans différentes régions pour
sonder l'humeur de l'électorat émilie
dubreuil deux fois par semaine va nous
amener dans des univers très différents
vont avoir des étudiants des gens
d'affaires
les gens des différentes communautés
culturelles à montréal on commence ce
périple d'emilie ce soir à la brasserie
du sud à longueuil
à peine nommé
la fameuse pâte de coing chambre
mais 80 septembre
aujourd'hui n'est pas ce que les gens
parlent encore de police et dans votre
taverne un peu moins d'impôts mais c'est
pas comme ada non les gens sont tannés
des élections de cette année là les
boîtes et si saab en mariée
c'était peut-être trouvé la paix
attendent en vain
allez-vous de politique depuis une
contagion qu'est-ce qu'on mandate alors
c'est quoi ces les grosses promesses
concepteur est premier on s'est très
vite ils feront pas la moitié de ce
qu'ils disent mais ça fait ça fait des
années que c'est comme ça c'est tout le
temps comme ça on reprenait
et qui font des promesses qui tient pas
les promesses
vaquez tous les codes pénaux politique
non non
allez vous voter oui oui bon
même si vous connaissez rien napolitaine
certaines alliés est ce que pour
personne que l'on allait voter à notre
place auront voté
les gars n'ont pas du tout ma secours
car il ya un pompage du v6 mais diable -
tenue de ville
oui
face à lula tous sont arrivés au lot
c'est odieux des riches qui eux
bbb moins que l'humain